il ya beaucoup de personnalités acteurs
chanteurs animateurs qui prennent la
parole dans les médias contre des sujets
qui les tiennent à coeur et ce qu'ils
font bien de le faire mal est donc vous
oui oui en fait à ceux qui qui qui
répondront j'aimerais leur dire pourquoi
il sait les personnalités est ce que ce
sont des soucis c'est pas des sur
citoyen mais ils sont pas sous citoyens
non plus ils ont droit de s'exprimer
alors moi je dis à chaque fois qu'ils
sont on n'est pas obligé de s'exprimer
surtout il ya des choses sur lesquelles
je c'est vrai que des fois j'ai pas dis
et je préfère écouter mon père mon avis
après ou des fois même ne pas en avoir
la chance
s'appelle l'intelligence jean michel
maire
mais mais mais voilà pourquoi il ne le
ferait pas avec moi en tout cas ça me
pose aucun problème alors pablo ton nom
alors moi c'est non parce que c'est
super dangereux bah ça peut être super
dangereux donner leur avis peuvent
donner leur avis ce qui pose problème
c'est plutôt des personnes on va dire
king l'eau par exemple quand elle dit
ouais le vaccin ils vont nous mettre
sais pas quoi dans l'autre sens ils vont
nous contrôler avec l'archevêché pas
quoi leur forêt était de minutes il ya
des jeunes qui la regarde c'est super
dangereux pour eux ils la voient comme
une star ils veulent faire exactement
pareil
elle n'a aucune crédibilité je pense
même ces débilités auprès d'un public en
même ray de certains jeunes c'est des
influenceurs des personnalités de télé
réalité qui évidemment n'ont pas de
crédibilité à vos yeux sauf et j'ai même
fait des millions de
gens jetés çà pour maigrir je sais pas
je suis plutôt d'accord avec toi
l'habilité la responsabilité médiatique
vous très important jean-michel oui la
question et pas mal posée mais
doivent-ils non mais peuvent-ils oui
évidemment on fait on fait ça aussi nous
on fait sa longueur de journée à
longueur de soirée à longueur
d'émissions mais vous c'est votre métier
vous vous êtes là
vous n'êtes pas là pour donner des
matches même c'est une ont payé pour ça
donc ça c'est une catastrophe voilà mais
après moi ce qui me gêne un peu c'est
qu'ils donnent leur avis moi parfois je
modère un peu et surtout depuis quelques
années surtout dans les blagues dans
l'humour c'est demander un peu on attend
c'est parfois ça peut être tout chic c
mais après mais ce qui m'énerve c'est ce
qu'ils donnent leur avis qui après se
réfugie derrière la vendetta la colère
des des réseaux etc ont poussé corones
on les pose pas mais a pratiquement
automne son âme il faut accepter après
la critique etc ça nourrit le débat moi
je suis pour ce genre de voilà que les
gens disent ce qu'ils pensent je me sais
bien c'est précieux sofia toi tu es très
suivie sur les réseaux notamment sur
instagram où tu partage son quotidien
est ce que t'étais à l'aise avec le fait
de prendre la parole sur des sur des
sujets sensibles est ce que tu le fais
oui si un jour il ya un sujet qui me
touche et c'est bien sûr que je le
ferais comme il l'a dit les
personnalités publiques c'est pas des
sous citoyens si on parle de liberté
d'expression on parle pour tout le monde
c'est à dire qu'ils ont droit aussi
s'exprimer après c'est vrai que comme on
est beaucoup si v etc faut mettre les
formes pour mettre les formes parce que
ça peut créer après des émeutes etc les
jeunes c'est vrai qu'ils prennent
beaucoup ça à coeur et et que c'est vrai
quoi il faut faut pas non plus dire des
propos
qui va des potes qui va dépasser leurs
propres pensées parce qu'après c'est
vrai qu'un acte pour s'exprimer ils vont
en faire de trop mais c'est ce que c'est
ce que disait pablo il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit appartement
mois là il veut une médiatique on est en
pleine confiance il faut faire attention
à ce que son propos soit me vraie source
et intelligent intelligible donc
l'exemple que tu avais cité pablo
effectivement c'est tout ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire la désinformation et
jusqu'à ma vie en fait soit après je
sais pas je me dis donc peut-être kimbo
je me rends pas compte mais moi à chaque
fois qu'elle ouvre la bouche je me dis
mais qu'il écoute enfin et puis si
lacroix surtout pour moi c'est une
blague c'est un peu comme les afida
turner etc elles donnent leur avis mais
au fond moi ça me passe je sais pas s'il
ya des gens qui se disent oh oui oh non
mais j'en avais bien sûr qu'elle a
éventé en dérision sur les jouets mis la
main sur sur les seuls à lyon de
personnes qui la suit sur instagram s'il
y en a même que 20000 qui croient à ce
qu'elle dit c'est dangereux elle a aucun
discernement sur ce qu'elle raconte ça
c'est clair en tout cas certaines
personnes qui devraient avoir du cerneux
mans par exemple comme véronique genest
donc et plutôt à la normale manque est
censé être adulte et un peu
effectivement modéré ses propos je suis
d'accord avec jean louis c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné aujourd'hui c'est
sain le débat au contraire il faut
donner son avis il faut ne pas être
muselés et défendre ses opinions en
revanche toute cette incitation à la
haine en ce moment surtout l'oeuvre dans
une serial également qu'il hante tout
cette incitation à au contraire de ne
plus fédérer c'est à dire de diviser ça
c'est très dangereux par exemple francis
lalanne qui donne son avis aussi sur les
plateaux qui va à l'enterrement des
frères bogdanoff sans le masque pourquoi
parce que pour donner son opinion bien
sûr à soir quelque chose mais en fait ça
c'est contre-productif complètement
c'est à dire qu' il n'est en fait que le
reflet de sa propre bêtise il est des
grès labellisé là-dedans charlotte dit
non ben jabr le nom sans faille avec la
question est mal posée en maintenant le
sens ce n'est pas un devoir d eau
charlotte c'est
de préparer l'examen oui pourquoi pas
bref je le disais c'est pas un devoir
quand une personnalité d'être un leader
d'opinion surtout si on n'est pas
reconnu pour ses opinions politiques je
veux dire par exemple il ya plein
d'influenceurs dès qu'il ya un combat un
peu à la mode qui reprennent ça pour
gagner en popularité alors qu'ils en
savent rien du tout pour moi faim chez
eux mais quand c'est pas on ferme sa
gueule là en l'occurrence on participe à
voilà une émission de talk show donc
moi-même shojaee de me transformer en
professeurs tournesol qui a un avis
tranché sur tout je sais que dans la vie
de tous les jours il ya plein de sujets
sur lequel j'ai pas forcément david sa
retraite et documenté et déroule très
bien charlotte c'est pourquoi vous avez
ce petit trophée devant vous